it is official the conservatorship of
britney spears has been terminated
this is the moment they found out she is
finally free
[Applause]
britney spears was 26 when her
conservatorship began she's now 39 and
for the first time in almost 14 years
back in control of her near 60 million
dollar fortune and her life
give us your reaction to oh my gosh you
guys she's free we're happy this is what
we wanted
what is freedom our first act she can
have her cell phone not monitored
she can hear children at will she can
leave her house when she wants to
basic human rights really i think this
is a great start now that she's actually
free i think
there's a lot more that still needs to
be done to investigating as to how this
corruption even went down
spears conservatorship started in 2008
after a mental breakdown it is an
extreme legal arrangement granted for
people who can no longer make their own
decisions in the years since the pop
star says it was abused she claimed she
was drugged forced to work and even
prevented from having more children
after the verdict spears posted this
picture i can't freaking believe it she
wrote best day ever
many people here say the termination of
this conservatorship is long overdue
they also say the fight for freedom for
britney spears is still ongoing
britney's own lawyers say she will now
have to decide whether to investigate
her father and his role in this
controversy
for 13 years jamie spears controlled his
daughter's estate and personal affairs
britney says he abused his position
jamie says he only acted in her best
interest what have you accomplished
today what does it mean for britney
spears
it means that britney is free
and is this the end of the story or does
the fight continue
to get justice for britney because a lot
of people believe this is long overdue
don't they i don't think it's the end of
the story
jamie spears he might be in the line of
target you may go after jamie spears
that depends on brittany
after the dust has settled she may
return to the stage but this time it
will be on her terms martha calmer sky
news los angeles